you and I have sat down before and
you're saying don't play Ashley Madison
for cheating it's a marketplace buyers
and sellers we're just here to connect
them but don't you think you promote
cheating you make it a lot more
accessible for those who are just
thinking about it
well I don't know that needs any
promotion right I think we we do a good
job of pursuing it all our own I think
what I do is try and perfect the affair
it does have collateral damage sometimes
you know you talked earlier about
secondhand smoke a single person on a
singles dating site wants no part of an
affair so bringing two like-minded
people together I think that's been the
secret sauce behind Ashley Madison dan
is is Noel providing the world a service
connecting quote unquote buyers and
sellers so you know in the in the
earlier segment I mentioned that if you
buy somebody a beer in the sandwich I'll
start liking you more I have to confess
that no has bought me a really good
dinner at some point in Toronto sorry
and I well I how could you not like him
no but so so I have I have some bias
plus he gave us lots of data to look at
some of the questions that Ashley
Madison are coming I I actually met no
because we were doing with doing a movie
on on dishonesty and trying to
understand this phenomena so we've
interviewed insider trading and
accounting frauds but also some people
that create a markets and know brought
lots of interesting questions to to the
table in this in this case including the
question of how long should marriages
last but back to this back to this issue
of is is he creating a marketplace I
think he yes but I think he is but isn't
providing a service remember we talked
earlier about good and bad and what's
fair and what's unfair and also when it
comes to dishonesty it's only dishonest
if you lie to your husband or if you lie
to your wife that's right so there's no
question that this is a market for
dishonesty this is not a market where we
providing a kind of mechanisms for
people to have open marriages this is
not a harmony well there's also a lot of
dishonesty in eHarmony but but if you
think about open marriages open
marriages if nobody's lying to their
spouse in this in this environment if
people are lying to their spouse and I
think there's a question of whether this
is in
urging more of this behavior or not and
I suspect it is and I suspect it's
encouraging more behavior because it
seems more socially acceptable you go
there's a big site you think lots of
people are part of this in fact it's an
amazing how many people are part of this
I think if I remember the numbers like
25 million members that that's a lot of
a lot of numbers we basically gives you
social proof high everybody else is
doing it it must be it must be okay I
think the question is that interest me
is whether it's increasing happiness
right so one of the people were
interviewed for this movie she's a user
of one of the the sides and she said in
her mind her real dishonesty is her life
with her regular husband because that
relationship is just incredibly
dysfunctional and in fact living is a
lie partner that's what this is her
opinion now it's not representative of
everybody but that's it by the way do
you know what's the best predictor of
the ratio between men and women on
Ashley Madison what do you think is the
best predictor of the ratio so some some
places there's more men than women
sometimes there's more women than men
what do you think predicts hey I mean
now it's answer equality in salaries so
in places where men have more power the
ratio of men to women is very met the
many more men than women but as salaries
become more equal their number of men
and women become more similar which
tells you that that women one of the
barriers for women to join is the driver
it's the driver is basically rated
inequality of salary no so if when
you're prospecting for new markets for
Ashley Madison is that something that
you look for income equality absolutely
the first foreign expansion we did
outside of America was in Australia when
we looked at Australia it was
fascinating right female prime minister
the wealthiest woman in the world lives
in Australia universities have a greater
female population professions have more
women at higher income earning so we
thought that was a great marketplace to
address because dan is exactly right the
more that we remove the speed bumps that
we put in front of female infidelity
which is we don't paint them with
scarlet letters we don't take away their
children for example if we find out
they've been unfaithful those are all
behavior patterns we
used to do we remove them and the more
we give them the economic freedom that
if their relationship did break down
they could still take care of themselves
in their family it turns out the more
likely they are to be unfaithful what
about what about how is the economy
affected who's participating in Ashley
Madison does it down market need more
people want to play because it's free to
have sex yeah you know what ends up
happening in a down market let's call it
it is a few things one divorce becomes
very tricky right you might not be able
to Val your home and move on with your
life pay a divorce attorney do all those
kinds of things and so people are still
technically married but really they've
lost the connection and so they look to
pursue outside relationships and so we
do incredibly well in that but also you
know the majority of marital discord
does tend to center around home
economics and so when you need your
partner the most say you've lost your
job you don't always get them the most
right you get more concern and worried
and so you look for comfort in a bunch
of places it turns out you sometimes
look for comfort in the arms of another
and so we are almost not just a
recession proof business but a recession
growth business Dan no we'll just
mentioned that stigmatizing adultery has
a negative effect on on women what about
we talked earlier about banning junk
food what about banning something like
Ashley Madison he tried to open up at
Singapore right Singapore said no thank
you
what effect does that have so thank you
to Ashley Madison but they have no
problem having prostitutes so so I think
I think that for me the question is
really about happiness and how do we get
people to be happy in the long term and
I think if you think about junk food I
think junk food gives short term
happiness at the expense of long term
misery right so I think there's a bad
trade-off and I think if you showed
somebody and said this is a decision
somebody else is doing it is the right
decision
I think infidelity is much more much
more complex than that and I think that
lots lots of people are in relationships
that they really are having no sexual
gratification and no happiness and death
aspects of life and the question is
should they stay in this in this
relationship or not and breaking up is
one possibility with lots of lots of
cost and stepping out of the
relationship is another possible
here's the thing about honesty and
honesty most things in life is a
trade-off with other values and it's
really hard to figure out how you
trade-off honesty with with other values
so with honey you look great in that
dress that's not the trade-off of
honesty with another but honey you look
great in that dress is often from a
voice that you can't hear anymore your
spouse know is one of the draws of
Ashley Madison that oxytocin high you
get when the email comes through because
for those who are living in the monotony
of monogamy they missed that hi and
Ashley Madison provides just that you
know it's fascinating I think you're
right on the money when we did some
research for the University of
California that's what they were looking
at what they called the female monogamy
gap what is motivating women to increase
the rates of infidelity everyone kind of
acknowledges that's what's really
driving this right male infidelity has
been kind of static released in
existence since time immemorial it's
female infidelity that's going to gone
hand-in-hand with the internet growth
and it turns out if it's all about that
it's being an object of desire women
want to rekindle that notion they felt
when they were being proposed to when
they were being flattered when their
life was really great that was the
happiest time it doesn't happen anymore
and so getting that attention you sign
up - Ashley Madison it doesn't matter
what city you're in how much you weigh
how old you are having a dozen people be
interested in meeting with you is part
of that and so yes I do think that's the
siren is in your research Navy
traditionally men do want to sleep
around they want to get laid all the
time but women is it about desire do
they actually want to have sex with
other people
or do they just want to be wanted do
they want that desire factor fulfilled
no they do on intimacy but they use the
word passion a lot more than they use
the word sex right which clearly means
sex plus something right it's hard for
them to find exactly where that is it
starts with being an object of desire it
tends to end up in a bed it does but it
you know 10% of the female users sign up
saying they just want something digital
something cyber and almost 50% of them
will change that within the first few
days and so you see a lot of behavior
patterns that lead people to realize
that it becomes like an entry point the
entry point is signing up to the service
and thinking about it but once you
connect with somebody that does seem to
understand you does want to pay
attention to you you're willing to take
that to the next level
Nowell quickly then talks about the
importance of honesty do you and
courage your customers to be honest with
their spouses about what they're doing
oh come on no III rana CLE the honesty
part of our massing is within the
platform you know dating online dating
tends to be a fairly dishonest place as
dan can attest to ironically Ashley
Madison is one of the more honest places
this is the place that people tend to
post realistic photos tell their same
age because they're taking a huge risk
as it is they don't want to then meet
somebody and then find out all this is
going to blow up in their face and so
it's ironic but that's what happens on
Ashley Madison